sda
sie liest
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
weihnachtsbäckerei samira und ich wir
haben uns dieses jahr wieder ganz
leckere weihnacht rezepte ausgesucht und
werden die jetzt für euch backen
bei uns gibt es nämlich jedes jahr
weihnachtsplätzchen das war auch schon
bei uns zu hause so obwohl wir beim mit
meinen eltern auch noch nie weihnachten
gefeiert haben meine eltern und wer wir
sind der muslime und bei uns feiert man
kein weihnachten aber trotzdem backen
wir gerne weihnachtsplätzchen zur
weihnachtszeit weil wir natürlich auch
viele nicht muslimische freunde haben
und dann wird es einfach gemeinsam
gefeiert
unsere freunde feiern mit uns ramadan
und opferfest und wir feiern dann mit
ihnen weihnachten und ich finde gerade
die weihnachtszeit so richtig schön
dafür fällt ja jeder in so eine
fröhliche stimmung und dann wird
gemeinsam gebacken und dekoriert und das
finde ich ganz besonders schön
und deswegen gibt es dieses jahr ganz
viele leckere rezepte mit samira zu
weihnachten und heute gibt es ein
richtig leckeres rallye dem rezept von
uns und zwar werden wir dazu und machte
mandl pralinen machen habe so schwierig
und die werden dann in schokolade
getaucht und dann nochmal in gehackten
man nie gewählt und ich zeige euch jetzt
mal die zutaten
wir brauchen hier zehn datteln die sind
schon erscheint eine prise salz und
viertel teelöffel zimt pfeffer etwas
vanillemark und wir brauchen 150 gramm
mandeln und ich habe die bereits in
heißes wasser gelegt und zwar werde ich
jetzt gleich heute das geht dann ganz
einfach die waren jetzt ganz lange in
kochendem wasser gelegen und dann seht
ihr kann ich hier einfach die haut
abziehen und dann sind die mandeln
gehäutet und von denen rauchig dann 150
gramm kommt es jetzt mal machen und wir
brauchen hier 100 grad wird der
kuvertüre werde ich gleich noch
schmelzen und 100 gramm gehackte mandeln
die mandeln sind jetzt gehäutet und ich
werde jetzt aber zuerst mal die
schokolade hacken einfach im mixer weil
es einfach sehr schnell geht und dann
kann ich die schokolade schon mal
auflösen und inzwischen die pralinen
vorbereiten und in den gefrierbeutel
fühle ich jetzt die schokolade ein und
lässt sie dann im gefrierbeutel
schmelzen
das geht einfach am schnellsten und vor
allen dingen macht man da keinen dreck
einfach kurz verschließen
und so kann man die schokolade vor allem
auch gut funktionieren weil ich kann
dann zum beispiel mit der geschmolzene
schokolade schreiben oder dekorieren und
ich benutzt sie dann auch gleich
portionsweise einfach gut verschließen
und jetzt in den topf mit heißem wasser
legen das darf halt nicht mehr kochen
und das stelle ich es kurz zur seite und
bereits schon mal die füllung vor
dafür nehme ich einfach wieder den
miezen da kommen jetzt erst mal die
mandeln rein
tschuldigung du darfst nächster und
jetzt werden die kleinen gemixt und
jetzt kommt da noch die datteln mit dazu
noch zwei auch zimt und salz
und ich gebe noch ein bisschen vanille
extrakt dazu ganz kleines bisschen
das ist nämlich hoch konzentriert und
ist in öl eingelegt und das riecht auch
richtig lecker aber wenn ihr kein
vanille extrakt habt könnt auch einfach
vanillezucker nehmen am besten den
selbstgemachten oder ein bisschen wir
nochmal so jetzt wird wieder gemixt
die masse sieht jetzt so aus ziemlich
klebrig und ich habe jetzt schon mal
einen weg handschuhe an weil ich mich
gleich sonst ziemlich dreckig machen
ich nehme diese masse jetzt heraus und
wer einfach mal portionieren unterricht
richtig lecker richtig orientalisch
irgendwie auch orientalisch
weihnachtlich bastian hatte das gleich
mit lassen nämlich gleich helfen beim
kugel formen das erst mal die ganze
masse zusammen
ich glaube dass wir auch richtig lecker
mit getrockneten feigen mir auch so
lecker und aromatisch
guck mal jetzt vor ort formen wird es
hier zu einer rolle
die hat jetzt ungefähr 3 cm im
durchmesser und da schneide ich mir
jetzt schreiben mit einem zentimeter
runter
du darfst jetzt zu einer kugel formen
richtig schön richtig schön rund ok
einfachrunde kugeln formen tolle sache
du bist meine konditorin die schokolade
ist schon schön geschmolzen und ich habe
oben jetzt eine spitze abgeschnitten
jetzt gebe ich mir so einen klecks auf
meiner hand
deswegen habe ich jetzt auch die einweg
handschuhe an gibt eine praline drauf
und schroll sie jetzt zusammen und dann
setze ich sie hier rein guckt mal das
sagst du machen und so ein bisschen
schütteln und dann könnt ihr die
pralinen einfach mit seiner im löffel
rausheben und auf einen teller geben
die fertigen kugeln sehen dann ganz
lecker aus und ich habe sie jetzt
bereits schon im kühlschrank etwas
abkühlen lassen damit die schokolade
festwirt und wir werden jetzt mal
probieren
also diese nicht penetrant system nicht
also also süß aber nichts zu suchen soll
ich lasse mir so eine richtig feine süße
nicht zu dominant ich bin da wird sogar
ein bisschen rosenwasser mit rein passen
oder ein paar feigen also das war
richtig lecker
dann wird's noch mal orientalisch und so
schmeckt richtig lecker fein diese zimt
note ist noch mit dabei man könnte auch
lebkuchengewürz nehmen also dass ein
richtig leckere pralinen die ich jetzt
anpacken werde ihn so hübschen döschen
oder so hübschen kleinen tütchen die
gibt's einfach so einzeln mit diesen
kleinen karton und da ist auch noch so
ein süßes band mit dabei und den karton
kann man einfach unten einklappen machen
und dann packe ich jetzt die pralinen in
diese tüte ein
und dann kann man so richtig schön
verschenken
und das wird übrigens mein
weihnachtsgeschenk dieses jahr an meine
freunde und meine nachbarn und bekannte
ich finde nämlich viel schöner wenn man
einfach was selber macht vor allen
dingen was leckeres zu essen macht und
nicht einfach los geht und was kauf
verkaufen kann ja jeder
und beim selbstgemachten steckt einfach
viel liebe mit drin und ich finde das
schenkt man auch so ein stück zeit den
menschen weil man sich einfach die zeit
nimmt das für diesen menschen zu machen
und das wirklich so süß
ja also das was er hier alles zählt das
ist alles aus unserem ihres händen
entstanden
die hübsche weihnachtsdekoration leicht
übertrieben also ja ich fühle mich hier
gerade wie im winter wonderland in new
york oder keine ahnung wo total viel
dekoration hatte sich doch ganz süß ich
meine dieser mira sieht es ja auch
überall bei freunden und überall im
kaufhaus wird schön dekorierten damit
sie das natürlich auch zu hause haben
und das haben die beiden jetzt gemacht
und nicht damit überrascht mich also in
der gefällstrecke die leckeren pralinen
sind jetzt richtig hübsch verpackt und
ich kann sie verschenken am besten
lagert er sie kühl im kühlschrank da
sind sie etwa nur woche haltbar
wobei ich verzweifle dass ich so lange
halten weil man sie einfach viel zu
schnell aufgegessen hat und das rezept
gibst du nachlesen auf sallys blog.de
ich habe übrigens letztes jahr auch
schon richtig leckere weihnachtskonzerte
gemacht die gibt's auf meinem youtube
kanal oder eben auch auf meinem blog
alle zum nachlesen
da könnte auf jeden fall mal
vorbeischauen da habe ich zum beispiel
ein lebkuchenhaus gebacken und ganz
viele andere tolle sache und das war
jetzt mein erstes weihnachts video in
diesem jahr aber natürlich folgen noch
ganz viele weitere ideen und rezepte und
anregungen die kommen dann in meinen
nächsten videos und lasst euch da
einfach mal überraschen
ihr könnt mir aber schon mal schreiben
was eure lieblings rezepte sind und was
euer lieblings weihnachtsgebäck ist und
was er zur vorweihnachtszeit einfach am
liebsten macht das würd mich
interessieren wir sind gerne auf
weihnachtsmärkten und da verbringen wir
gerne zusammen mit familie und freunden
unsere zeit
ich kann mir jetzt mit meinem mann
richtig leckere heiße schokolade und ich
wünsche euch noch ganz viel spaß beim
nachhaken beim zubereiten und beim
genießen
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder
ab
übrigens findet ihr alle produkte die
ich heute benutzt habe auch bei mir im
shop auf sallys - shop.de und ich
wünsche euch jetzt einfach eine richtig
schöne besinnliche weihnachtszeit
genießt die zeit mit euren freunden mit
eurer familie bis bald